what's your view on this should the
government reduce further the isolation
period they've already cut it last week
from 10 days to seven do you think they
should go further still and take it down
to five days like they're doing in the
states
at the cbi in the summer we released a
document talking about
living with the virus we updated that
in december
and said it is now about living with the
variance we said how can we stop
lockdowns by following certain measures
including for example using
mass testing as opposed to mass
isolation and that's something i
personally fought for going back to
august 2020 the government eventually
listened the cbi got behind it and now
we have some of the best lateral flow
testing availability in the world where
it's shown time after time whether it's
oxford university ucl harvard have
proven if you do regular lateral flow
tests it picks up individuals who can
then if necessary isolate and the rest
can carry on going to school carrying
out university care and going to work so
that is sir john bell professor john
bell has said just now that we need to
continue using those lateral protests as
much as possible including reducing the
isolation period so i personally thought
it was fantastic news when sergeant
jarvid announced the isolation has gone
down from 10 days to seven days where if
you test negative on day six and seven
with lateral protests you can go back to
work
and the americans of course have now
gone down to five days and there are
those who say the american scientists
have said it is safe to do that and that
is asymptomatic individuals that they
can after five days asymptotic
individuals can stop their isolation
they carry on wearing a mask for a
further five days uh if the americans
are able to do it i'm sure our
scientists are looking at it and our
government is looking at it as well
and would you like them to go for it
we have got to go for as
low and isolation paired as is safe to
do because the disruption that is being
caused at the moment is huge if you can
imagine businesses what we have suffered
it throughout this pandemic with periods
of lockdown where businesses have
literally closed my own business with
with cobra beer we supply 7 000
restaurants they've been shut for months
on end and this december where
restaurants hotels bars they rely on a
huge proportion of their profits to be
made in the lead after christmas was
ruined because of the omicron virus so
we've had enormous disruption we've got
to stop that disruption and must as much
as possible to stop the effect on lives
and livelihoods as much as possible just
given a chance business rebounded very
quickly our economy suffered one of the
worst in the world in 2020 by dropping
by almost 10 percent we're still not
back to pre-pandemic levels i know that
this economy given a chance we can
bounce back very strongly and very
quickly and if it is safe to do so we
should be allowed to do so business has
gone to huge lengths to make their
premises kobit safe whether it's
restaurants whether it's offices
enormous expense and time has been spent
on that we'll do everything we can
and if there's a little disruption as
possible that's got to be good for the
country and good for the economy as long
as it's safe to do so
south africa where you are now did
introduce a policy just a few days ago
of no isolation for asymptomatic
individuals they've now already reversed
that is that a sign that it's a really
tough call it's a big decision that
countries around the world are wrestling
with getting this balance between
stopping the spread of the virus
keeping people safe but also keeping
industry and the economy going
i've spoken to experts over here in
south africa and there is still
confusion about exactly what is going to
happen now but on the 23rd of this month
they announced that it would no longer
be necessary to isolate uh for and and
because they've discovered that their
hospitals the icus are
nowhere near as full as they were with
the delta and the beta variant people
who were in hospital for delta and beta
for eight days have been in hospital for
three days with omicron the ventilators
are hardly being used so they found that
the hospitalizations and debts are much
much lower on the other hand there is no
running away from it this is hugely
infectious and and so they decided from
a practical point of view to change the
rules now we don't know exactly what
it's going to be now it will be
announced officially soon but i think
the way the direction things are heading
in now is recognizing that we've got to
live with the variance going forward in
a safer manner and practical a manner as
possible using lateral protests using
our world-leading booster program which
is fantastic we can protect our citizens
our businesses with two lines of defense
one is the vaccines next you have the
lateral flow testing the third that now
people are finally talking about we've
been calling out this since january is
having repurposed new treatments and the
antivirals for example the fisa
antiviral has shown in trials to reduce
deaths and hospitalizations by 89
once that becomes available that is a
game changer in that you treat people
they take the tablets for five days and
you reduce the hospitalization and death
so the combination of those things i
think is looking very optimistic ahead
we've got to get through this period
right now
you talk about the importance of mass
testing and the the valuable
contribution to that made by lateral
flow tests are you concerned at all that
we are getting warnings from pharmacists
today about the difficulty of of getting
hold of lateral flows in some areas
apache supply problems currently does
that worry you when everyone's building
up to go back to work after the
christmas and new year period
absolutely the government has got to do
everything it can to have these lateral
protests freely available just earlier
this month we ran out and that is not a
good situation to be in because the cost
of these natural blue tests if you put
that cost
into context of the billions it costs
when you restrict the economy even with
plan b let alone a lockdown those costs
it cost us 400 billion pounds to save
the economy and businesses and
livelihoods throughout this pandemic the
cost of having a huge supply of freely
available natural field tests to
businesses and to people in their homes
or to pick up from pharmacies is the
cost benefit is off the scales you just
must have as many lateral protests uh as
we can because they are shown now time
and again to be reliable
and helping to identify people who have
covered we must use them to the maximum
government must make them freely
available and continue to have them
freely available going forward at least
into the spring
lord bilamoria thanks so much for your
time interesting to talk to you thank
you
thank you